الهجمات واستعرت الحرب
السيبرانية التي تتعرض لها منشآت
بغداد في هذا الصدد. في حين نفى
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
روسيا وبعضهم مرتزقة هدفهم المال
القتال بالقرب من المواقع
تهتز له الارض بينهم تختفي
الاسماء الحقيقية لتحل مكانها
الدول عادت الى شيء قديم جدا
ربما اثري بالنسبة للغرب. انه
الفحم واخرى شغلت المفاعلات
النووية لتوليد الطاقة. لكن بعض
اوروبا تحاول الاستعداد لمواجهة
السلاح الروسي. فدول عادت الى
اوروبا عقوباتها اشهر بوتين
سلاحه الاساسي ضدها سلاح الطاقة.
ام نسج من الخيال ام هي مجرد
دراما فقط لتسطو الصين على
يبدو بانه قاس في ظل توترات
كبيرة مع روسيا. ومنذ بدأت
الترند العالمي? اوروبا تقيد
الحطب? لم تنتهي اوروبا بعد من
يرسل النظام احد الاقمار او
جميعها لاعتراضه. الصين بدأت في
نشر الباحثون في مجلة علوم
المعلومات بكين تخطط لاطلاق نظام
سيطرة. حامية الارض. ليست افلام
كرتون بل هي حقيقة وواقع. الصين
الصاروخ منخفضة للغاية. فيما
اوضحت صحيفة واشنطن بوست ان هناك
ولربما الاخير من زيارة رئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي نانسي
بيلوسي لتايوان التحذير جاء هذه
المرة بلهجة حادة وواضحة وتضمن
مساعدات مالية لاوكرانيا بمئات
الاف الدولارات. اول رد جاء من
والبحرين بعدما وقعتا اتفاقية
الدفاع الجوي مع اسرائيل فما هو
هجمات سرية ضد اسرائيل. الحرس
الثوري ان تعرضت ايران لاي عدوان
فالرد سيكون على ارض المعتدي. في
رسالة غامضة ايرانية للامارات
بالمسؤولية عن الهجمات مقابل
تلمح ايران الى انها تنفذ بنفسها
الفلسطينيين فاي نخوة هذه التي
لدى الشعب الجزائري ازدادت
الحرب الروسية في اوكرانيا اثرت
على كثير من العلاقات لابد ان
يكون لاسرائيل حصة من معركة
الصدامات هذه. فمن موقف الحياد
علمت تايوان باقتراب الغزو
الصيني لها؟ سوء العلاقات. لان
السواحل التركي يطارد زورقا
يونانيا تحرش بغارب شراعي. بعد
تتويجه بالفضية في سباق ثمانمائة
متر في مدينة يوشين الامريكية في
الاوكراني قواتنا البحرية رصدت
سفن انزال روسية في البحر
المغزى? الصين تقدم نفسها الحامي
الاول للكرة وفي الوقت ذاته تهدد
امريكا وتستعد لاجتياح تايوان من
يمكنه ايقاف اصحاب العيون
فلسطين وبذلك تظل الجزائر
المدافع الاول عن قضية اشقائهم
الاسود. زلنسكي يدعو روسيا لترفع
الحصار عن البحر الاسود غفر
بطولة العالم لالعاب القوى
الجزائري جمال سيجاتي يرفع علم
وزير التجارة التشيكي براج تسمح
لروسيا بتهديد امنها. الجيش
وبسبب هذه الضربات يتناقص
المقاتلون الاجانب في جيش كييف.
المسيطرة على مدينة ايزوم شرق
اوكرانيا يتحصن مقاتلون
اخرى حركي يختلفون في اللغة
والثقافات منهم المتطوعون لقتال
بعلاقات البلدين. جون كيربي
سنوفر للاوكرانيين قدرات صاروخية
بعيدة المدى في خطوة خطيرة من
امريكا قد تجرها للحرب ضد روسيا.
تورط قواته في الهجوم واعتبره
عملا ارهابيا يهدف للاضرار
حيوية ايرانية وفي كل مرة تتهم
طهران اسرائيل او جماعات تدعمها
واليوم اعلنت الدفاع الروسية
انها قتلت اربعين مرتزقا
بولنديون ودمرت ثمانية مراكز
قيادة اوكرانية بحسب ما قالت
الهجوم على محافظة دهوك العراقية
واعرب عن للتحقيق الذي تجريه
الاحداث والتطورات. العراق يقدم
ادلة الى مجلس الامن بتورط تركيا
في مجزرة استهداف دهوك بصواريخ
بينما ادان مجلس الامن الدولي
الاجانب يتناقصون. على بعد
كيلومتر واحد من المواقع الروسية
بصريين على القطبين الجنوبي
والشمالي للقمر لمراقبة السماء
الحطب في سيناريو مؤلم للقارة
العجوز في الشتاء المقبل.
اوكرانيون واجانب في قبو رغم
ظلمته فانه يشكل ملجأ قصف روسي
بناء المشروع ويتوقع اطلاقه
بنهاية العام الحالي فهل هو واقع
السلطات باجراء محاكاة لاخلاء
الشوارع بعد انذار بهجوم صاروخي.
اعداد المقاتلين الاجانب في
اوكرانيا. اوروبا لم تعد الى
الروسية يحمل العديد من المخاطر
ما دفع الكثير منهم للرحيل.
موجات الحرارة وازمة حتى شرعت
بالتفكير في الشتاء المقبل. شتاء
احتمالية كبيرة لسقوط الصاروخ في
مياه احد المحيطات. وهذه هي
كوكبي مسلح لحماية الارض من
هجمات الكويكبات القادرة على
وزارة الخارجية الصينية اكدت ان
احتمالية وقوع اضرار بسبب سقوط
تدمير مدن باكملها. الاستراتيجية
تتضمن وضع ثلاثة اقمار صناعية
الثالثة التي تترك فيها الصين
صاروخا يهبط على الارض دون
بحثا عن كويكبات هربت من شبكة
الارض للانذار وعند رؤية الكويكب
في مدار القمر واقمار صناعية
تحمل كميات من الوقود فبحسب ما
للحراسة. مزودة باسلحة وتدور حول
الكوكب لرصد التهديدات وتلسكوبين
تعلن نفسها حامية للعالم من
الاخطار. ايعقل هذا? باسلحة تطير
داخل الاوساط الامريكية الرسمية.
وكالة الامن القومي الامريكي
سقوطه غير خبراء يتخوفون من سقوط
حطام صاروخ صيني جديد ترك يهوي
صائبة في الوقت الحالي. فقدان
السيطرة. خارج عن السيطرة ومكان
تدرس مدى جدية التهديدات حتى ان
الرئيس جوف بايدن بنفسه اعتبر
في سماء سوريا وردعتها من القصف
هناك رغم ان تل ابيب تقول ان هذا
والثاني جاء باعلان اسرائيل ان
الصواريخ الروسية لاحقت طائرات
منذ ربع قرن ومقررة اغسطس
المقبل. والغريب انها مسار للجدل
نحو الارض يزن ثلاثة وثمانين
طنا. هذا الصاروخ يرعب العالم.
عسكريا. مسؤول امريكي قال ان
الصين سترسل مقاتلات وتعلن منطقة
روسيا. ما زاد الطين بلة هو
اعلان تل ابيب رسميا انها سترسل
حدث لمرة واحدة لكن شرارة الحرب
يتم اشعالها ولا تزال نارها
الزيارة غير الضرورية والجيش
الامريكي يرى ان الفكرة غير
تايوان ظهرت بزيها العسكري على
سطح سفينة حربية تقود وتتابع فهل
حظر جوي فوق سماء الجزيرة.
الزيارة هي الارفع لمسؤول امريكي
سيسقط الصاروخ الصيني المرعب?
واي دولة ستحل بها الكارثة?
المتحدة تتحدى روسيا بهذه الخطوة
مرة اخرى ينتظر العالم متى واين
يتجلى في ملف اغلاق ممثلية
الوكالة اليهودية للهجرة في
من الخلاف. فما الذي يحدث؟
الواضح حتى الان. ان العلاقات
روسيا برفض استقبال وفد اسرائيلي
لتسوية ازمة الوكالة يهودية.
الروسية الاسرائيلية تتدهور منذ
اشهر وكثيرة هي الاسباب اخرها
اجراءات حازمة وقوية. نوعية الرد
الذي ستقدم عليه بكين قد يكون
الفور وتقول الصين ان تايوان جزء
لا يتجزأ من اراضيها. ولا تستبعد
رسائل نصية طالبت السلطات الناس
بالانتقال الى اماكن امنة على
هادئة. التحذير الاخير. تحذير
صيني هو الثاني خلال اسبوع
وعرض الوساطة تدرجت تل ابيب
لتأخذ موقعها من الاصطفاف وكذلك
واصدرت اوامر باخلاء الطرق
والبقاء في المنازل. ودوت صافرات
الانذار لاخلاء الشوارع اجباريا
للقيام بالتدريبات التي تسببت في
بالسيادة عليها. وتتعهد بالدفاع
عن نفسها. في اكبر مناورات لمنع
العدو من الوصول الى العاصمة.
اطلقتها تايوان. حتى ان رئيسة
ابدا الاستيلاء عليها بالقوة.
وترفض تايوان مطالب الصين
اغلاق بلدات ومدن في انحاء شمال
تايوان لمدة نصف ساعة. وعبر
فعلتها الصين حقا? وهكذا هددت
بكين واشنطن الذي يحدث? الولايات
والجزائر تحرج العالم العربي
والغربي وايران تبعث برسالة
مجلس الامن بينما تستعر حرب من
نوع اخر بين طهران وتل ابيب
تلاحق طائرات الكيان فهل هي
الحرب بينهما? لكن لماذا تتناقص
الفحم فقط بل عادت الى ما هو
قبله. والعراق يصل بقضيته الى
غامضة للامارات والبحرين. فما
الذي تريده? تايوان تتحضر للحرب.
علاقات روسيا باسرائيل من سيء
الى اسوأ? والصواريخ الروسية
نحن هنا ونعلنها للعالم سنخلص
الكرة الارضية من كل شروط. هذه
تدوي في تايوان والناس يهرعون
للملاجئ. ما هو السبب يا ترى? هل
ليست جملة النمر المقنعة الشهيرة
فحسب بل انها صارت رمزا لاصحاب
الضيقة.
العيون الضيقة فكيف للصين ان
تحمي العالم? صافرات الانذار